tioman now where the saudi-led coalition
has announced that it's easing
restrictions to allow sunna airport to
reopen the coalition says it'll mean
patients in need of medical care can be
phone out from the rebel-held area
flights will be operated in cooperation
with the World Health Organization the
airport has been closed to commercial
flights since 2016 yarn Eggland's is the
secretary-general of the Norwegian
Refugee Council which has been working
in Yemen for several years now joins me
now on skype via Oslo you must be very
relieved to hear this news and that this
operation is about to happen we are this
is a reg Lima of Hope in a in a
desperate war situation for four years
we've asked for Sanaa Airport to be
reopened for these medical flights but
also for other commercial and civilian
flights this is is a place where which
always had to send patients out of the
country because they couldn't care for
the worst and most complicated medical
treatments then the airport was closed
at the same time as the medical systems
in Yemen collapsed so for years now
we've seen thousands dying unnecessary
and for those hopeless over but for many
patients there is now hope that they can
get abroad and get treatment mr. Coad
your your organization is one of many
humanitarian organizations helping those
in Yemen how will you or can you or hope
to coordinate your efforts with the
World Health Organization how does that
relationship work well it's really the
World Health Organization but also
UNICEF that is and several other NGOs
who are lead on the medical site World
Health Organization will now be
coordinating this with the government of
Yemen and I hope that this air medical
air bridge will start you know
imminently
but of course the whole medical system
needs to be rebuilt half of hospitals
and clinics and so on are inoperable at
the moment and of course while they're
out of action
people still needed to get medical
treatment from your knowledge and
experience how difficult was it to get
patients out of the country and how did
that actually happen well many people
then just died waiting for an
opportunity to fly out from the Sanaa
Airport others would try to go you know
15 hours by Road through roadblocks and
crossing front lines to the southern
port of Aden to get out others would not
have the resources to do that and then
they just silently died from cancer or
heart disease or liver disease kidney
problems that could have been treated
abroad hopefully this can be a turning
point really it is a positive mood by
the Sun saudi-led coalition it's also
positive that we're hearing about
possible prisoner exchanges there was
the Reard agreement making peace between
the those forces fighting each other in
the south there are talks between the
Houthi
Ansar Allah government and the saudi-led
coalition there is an opportunity to end
this senseless war I mean that is the
reality in perhaps that might be the
common sense view that those of us
outside of Yemen may see and may look at
but at the end of the day the reality is
that this is a very sensitive situation
and negotiations and talks can easily
break down this window of opportunity
that's now beginning from the airport
through the World Health Organization is
that very much a window of opportunity
how long would you like to see it open
for what this medical you know airbridge
out should now be permanently there it
was wrong totally wrong too closer than
the first place civilians should not die
because
men fight politically and militarily
there there are there are many
opportunities now to see that we can
start the peace efforts what we are
still saying is that this remains the
largest humanitarian crisis on earth ten
million people are on the brink of
starvation 2019 was not a good year as
many thought it would be after the
Stockholm agreement in in in a year from
now December 2018 350,000 people more
than that have been displaced because of
violence this year alone in England we
will leave it there we know you've been
a passionate supporter of the civilians
in Yemen I'm sure they will get some
respite certainly from this news that's
coming out of the country for the moment
sir thanks for joining us from Oslo